Alice went down the rabbit hole without
asking many questions and you're about
to do the same watch until the end to
find out if Alice's experience happened
in real life or if it was all in her
head now let's get right to the dark
secrets in Alice in Wonderland Disney
didn't want you to notice curiosity and
the Cheshire Cat from the looks of it
Alice isn't a day over eleven years old
although she might be coming of age
she's still a child in every sense of
the word so despite being nursed into
adolescence by her parents all Alice
wants is to have a little fun so when
she stumbles across a white rabbit with
a pocket watch she chooses to let her
curiosity get the best of her peculiar
place to have a party
although Alice in Wonderland is a movie
for kids through and through there are
some pretty strong themes that jump out
at adults in this case Alice's last
words are still ringing in our ears
after all she did say that giving in to
curiosity could lead to some curious
events after falling down the rabbit
hole Alice encounters a world filled
with impossibility so we're led to
believe that curiosity did um
exterminate the cats but in this case
the cat represents Alice's old life or
childhood so to speak when young Alice
finally comes face-to-face with the
Cheshire Cat he instructs her on which
way to go problem is he keeps pointing
in dubious directions but I do want to
go among mad people oh by the end of
this scene it's obvious that Alice has
become one of the mad people she so
desperately fears in the end the
Cheshire cat admits to not being all
there which makes us wonder if Alice
isn't all there either could it be that
Wonderland is a figment of Alice's
imagination or did she really fall down
a magic rabbit hole the kid of hearts
the Queen of Hearts is someone to be
feared
after all she likes nothing more than to
see her servants heads come off on a
daily basis she's big proud and loud
making her the obvious ruler of
Wonderland however the same can't be
said about the King of Hearts who seems
to be more of a child than a leader
[Music]
[Applause]
and a king although the king is supposed
to be the main ruler his wife dismisses
him as does his kingdom in this scene
the Queen of Hearts becomes enraged when
she realizes that her white roses have
been painted red since white roses
represent innocence and beauty the red
roses represented love and lust we can't
help but feel as though the Queen wants
to keep her Kingdom innocent so in other
words the Queen of Hearts wants everyone
to remain childish so despite being
married to the king the Queen chooses to
treat him like a child in fact even the
artists behind Alice in Wonderland's
animation chose to make him no bigger
than a toddler knowing this we think
that the King should have been named the
kid of hearts because he comports
himself like a child would which is far
from king like painting the roses red
can symbolize growing up and those who
grow up in Wonderland tend to lose their
heads Tea Party the thought of having a
tea party with mysterious folk is all it
took for Alice to plunge into the
unknown despite not being invited to the
Mad Hatter's Tea Party Alice saw fit to
be in attendance when Alice spots the
Tea Party from afar she sees a cloud of
smoke and circling the table that when
she gets a closer look she sees that the
tea pots are the ones behind the steady
stream of steam after breathing in the
mysterious laughing gas Alice can
finally stoop down to a new level she
introduces herself to her new pals and
asks them if they are celebrating a
birthday only to be introduced to a new
concept so what's an unbirthday well
find out what the Mad Hatter and the
March Hare explain it to you themselves
[Music]
although this scene might seem
straightforward it's riddled with tons
of meaning when put under the scope this
Tea Party becomes a celebration of youth
we're so used to celebrating our
birthdays that we forget to enjoy the
rest of the year this Tea Party is a
celebration of innocence one that
reminds us that our regular days are
just as important as our actual
birthdays so basically Alice is learning
how to live in the present have you ever
noticed how children can't wait to
become big kids well this reminds them
to enjoy their youth while they're
living in it the pressures of growing up
if there are two characters that can get
on anyone's nerves its Tweedledee and
Tweedledum
when these twins are first introduced
into the plot they immediately rub Alice
the wrong way although they might look
childlike these characters seem to
represent adults just look at how they
place themselves by Alice's side when
she emerges from a hollow log this scene
can very well represent the birth and
how parents stand by our side and teach
us right from wrong Alice passes through
a dark log to find herself encircled by
strange figures who have much to teach
her tweet OD and Tweedledum latch on to
Alice like a parent does a child and
desperately try to stop her from
following the white rabbit but it's
clear that Alice wants nothing to do
with them she tries to escape their
clutches but they won't let her out of
their sight the identical twins changed
their tune when they find out that Alice
is curious instead of encouraging her
they tell her scary stories that make
her doubt herself this is something that
parents often do to children to keep
them safe so we're led to believe that
Tweedledee and Tweedledum are nothing
more than annoying parents of figures
who come to rein on Alice's parade a
nonsensical tail when stumbling into a
world like Wonderland it's only normal
to have a boatload of questions so when
Alice finally gets to the Tea Party she
wants nothing more than answers
unfortunately for her logical answers
don't seem to exist in Wonderland
throughout the film Alice is struggling
to find her voice and getting used to
being talked over
why
right when Alice gets her new friends
attention he dismisses her by slamming
his hammer and switching the subject it
is here that he utters the classic
riddle that many of us remember from the
Disney film why is a raven like a
writing-desk
this timeless riddle has puzzled many
people especially since no answer was
ever provided in 2010 Tim Burton
directed the movie Alice in Wonderland
which was filmed with real-life actors
at the end of the film Alice asks the
Mad Hatter for the answer to this riddle
and here's what he says so this puts an
end to the century-old riddle basically
there is no right answer because the
riddle makes no sense in the first place
this proves that Alice in Wonderland is
a nonsensical body of work but one that
teaches us many things along the way
gullible children Alice's slow descent
into Wonderland leaves her hungry for
more which is why she desperately opens
doors and crawls through tight spaces
before long she realizes that her
adventure isn't going to follow a linear
path
[Music]
Alice's voice of reason ends up being a
doorknob and it reminds her that she's
too big to pass through the door the
door to Wonderland is small enough for a
child to crawl through but Alice has
surpassed her childhood and is entering
her teenage years making her much too
big to fit through the opening instead
of turning her away the doorknob
encourages Alice to drink from a magic
potion look first drink Smok poised
before drinking the potion Alice gives
herself some advice but the doorknob
doesn't understand but he doesn't let
her statement get to his head young kids
often say things that make no sense to
adults but perfect sense to other
children but instead of trying to
understand them adults are quick to
dismiss their logic and even quicker to
encourage them to do as they say
although Alice knew that she would
regret drinking the potion she listened
to her guide and shrunk to three inches
tall
a sea of frustration shrinking to three
feet tall is no joke which is why Alice
is eager to be on her way
problem is the doorknob doesn't have
Alice's best interest at heart which is
why he lied to her for his own amusement
[Music]
after making her drink a random potion
the door reveals that he is locked but
instead of admitting that he tricked
Alice into drinking the potion he asked
her if she has the key when she admits
to not having it he tells her that she
must have forgotten the key on the table
knowing full well that she didn't you
see the key was never on the table in
the first place so it's obvious that the
doorknob is pulling Alice's strings once
again the pesky doorknob convinces Alice
to ingest something else he makes a box
of cookies appear out of thin air and
Alice takes a bite of the one that has
peakmi written on it after the first
bite Alice becomes a giant which amuses
the doorknob to no end
Alice reaches her breaking point as soon
as the doorknob starts to laugh at her
big salty tears start streaming down her
face causing the SIA frustration to
appear the doorknobs wicked ways cause
Alice to cry like a young child would
when met with a confusing scenario in
the end this scene can represent how
parents expect their kids to obey their
every
command and how their expectations can
cause temper tantrums to appear out of
thin air and much like the doorknob
parents usually regrets their actions
once the tears start falling peer
pressure most children have a hard time
forming their own opinions and how could
they not after all their parents have
been thinking for them since the day
they were born after being tricked by
the doorknob and stranded in the sea of
her own tears she's lost so she puts her
faith in the first person she sees which
is something many children do
but shouldn't Alice jumps from her
bottle to reunite with society only to
realize that they aren't going to help
her either she tries to join the group
but ends up getting stepped on and
ignored this scene is symbolic in more
ways than one the more obvious one being
that alice is having a hard time
integrating with society becoming a
teenager is no small feat which is why
many teens give to peer pressure to get
accepted into a social circle at this
point Alice is soaking wet and desperate
to get dry so when the dodo tells her
that running in the circle will get her
dry she only doubts him for a moment but
before long alice is giving in to
pressure and doing what the other sea
dwellers are doing who are you most of
us struggle to find out our own identity
for the majority of our lives so we're
not surprised that Alice had a hard time
answering the caterpillars redundant
questions mental awareness tends to kick
in around the time children turn into
adolescents during this time the body
goes through many changes making it hard
for individuals to know themselves
inside and out so when the caterpillar
starts asking Alice questions she fails
to answer them it goes without saying
that adults tend to expect great things
from young teens despite the fact that
they're still struggling to work things
out so when the caterpillar starts
getting frustrated with Alice's answers
he starts disrespecting her personal
space the caterpillar blows smoke into
her face and she inhales whatever it is
he's smoking without wanting to this
frustrates her causing her to storm off
although this teen might appear funny to
the passerby it might just symbolize why
teenagers tend to go through bouts of
anger and uncertainty Alice tries to
kick off the caterpillars pink smoke and
succeeds to be rid of his influence for
a little while coping mechanism many of
us have tried to figure out what the
real message behind Alice in Wonderland
is and while we all have our own
opinions some make more sense than
others as his trip to Wonderland is
something she's dreamed of which is why
it follows the guidelines she set out at
the beginning of the film this insert
proves that Alice likes to think outside
of the box and she's bored with how
mundane her world can be the thought of
reading books with no pictures in them
upsets her
which led her to say in the previous
statement wanting to live in a world
where every book has pictures in it
sounds a lot like not wanting to grow up
at all from where we're standing the
Wonderland is nothing more than a coping
mechanism one that Alice created to stop
herself from thinking and logically in
her eyes living in a nonsensical world
is the goal and abiding by normal
standards is the enemy in this scene we
clearly see that alice is attending a
tea party without an invitation
and since tea parties are only
young children this can prove that
Alice's border in adulthood and
desperately trying to backtrack all in a
dream
there are many clues that point towards
Alice's experience being nothing more
than a dream or a daydream at best
however a mighty wizard named Dumbledore
once said of course it is happening
inside your head Harry but why on earth
should that mean that it is not real
it's just a rabbit with a race code
analysis hallucinations start as soon as
the water begins to ripple indicating
that her reality has changed she dives
right into the nonsensical world she so
eagerly imagined only to realize that it
isn't the one she wants to live in
despite entering a new and wonderful
world
Alice ends up trying to escape it this
scene proves that Alice had in fact
fallen asleep and dreamed up Wonderland
but does this make the entire experience
fake perhaps the biggest and darkest
secret found in Alice in Wonderland is
that dreams can teach us the biggest
lessons of all Alice and while our
dreams might not make a lot of sense
they always find a way to make us look
forward to waking up and facing reality
once again so do you think that Alice
really went to Wonderland or was it all
a dream
let us know in the comments below and
that's a wrap thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]